[Music]
Hello, Secrets Unsealed family and
members of the Sum TV audience. This is
our question and answer program. I'd
like to know and we welcome you to this
particular sitting. We are so glad that
you are here. My name is CA Murray. I'm
in the company of our pastor and
founder, Pastor Steven Boore. Pastor,
always good to have you here. A pleasure
to work with you, CA. Always. And Pastor
David Salazar, who superintends our
Latino work, our Latino channel doing a
fine job. Pastor, always good to have
you and to share the desk with you.
Amen. Thank you for allowing me to be
with you as well. Again, as we said,
this is our question and answer program.
Should you want to become a part of this
program, you can do so very easily by
writing to us at TV at some suum as in
Mary tv.org.
TV
atsumtv.org and we will get to your
questions just as soon as we can just as
quickly as we can. We will answer them
from the word of God which is our pledge
that we make to you that if an answer
can be found we will indeed find it and
give it to you from the word of God.
Pastor Salazar, would you give us a word
of prayer before we begin? Absolutely.
Let's pray. Our gracious heavenly
father, we are so delighted that we can
come to you by faith to your throne of
grace and you have asked us that we can
ask all the things that we need and we
certainly need the influence the
direction of the Holy Spirit. Therefore,
we ask humbly that you grant this gift
to us so that as we answer, as we go
through this Bible, as we open your
word, we may be able to respond to the
questions with a thus said the Lord. I
thank you for your grace. Be with us
now. And we pray in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen. Amen. We always like to ask you to
identify where you are coming from along
with your name if you possibly can.
Occasionally we get some questions where
the person does not want to be
identified so they leave the name off.
But if you can give us the name and the
part of the world because we have
questions from around the world that
you're writing from. This one is from
Zer Zerai Chara which is a interesting
name. I wish I could know where this is
coming from, but we'll ask the question
anyway. Uh they say a closer look at
Exodus 20:es 8 through 11, that of
course is the fourth commandment of the
ten commandments, shows that all things
that are mentioned um to rest are all
living things, people and animals. Does
that mean we can give out our nonlife or
non-living property for use on Sabbath
since they don't need rest? Can I give
my car for someone to use on Sabbath if
they ask for it or a wheelbell or
anything else as long as it is not
living? That's the question, gentlemen.
What say ye?
Well, uh I think this person really
answered his or her only own question.
Uh we don't know whether Zes is a woman
or a man, but whoever asked this
question um answers their own question
because basically it says a closer look
at Exodus 28-11 shows that all things
that are mentioned to rest are all
living things, people and animals. Does
that mean we can give out our non-life
property for use on Sabbath since they
don't need rest? The bottom line is that
the question says that it's only living
things that are to rest. But I don't
know if uh pastor Salasar has another u
dimension to this. Well, I just would
like to maybe add to the expression that
the spirit prophecy says in regards to
keeping the Sabbath day holy. I'm
assuming this individual is quite
uh you know certain he wants to honor
the Lord and keeping the Sabbath day
holy. And so she mentions there's many
ver quotes but one that I think would
help us to to sort of answer this
question is found in councils to the for
the church page 263 paragraph 1. It says
there the Sabbath is not to be given for
the repairing of garments, to the
cooking of food, to pleasure seeking, or
to any worldly order worldly employment.
Before the setting of the sun, let all
secular work be laid aside and all
secular papers be put out of sight. So,
you know, if if this is
about work and receiving uh some sort of
uh income, some sort of uh uh employment
that what he's thinking of doing in the
Sabbath because it's not a living thing.
In that scenario, I think it'd be best
not to be, you know, participate. But it
is to help someone to lend a vehicle so
the friend can go and take his family to
see the doctor, the family, whatever.
Those are different scenarios. So as
long as you're not uh saying well you
know let me lend the car so that a
friend of mine um makes money on the
Sabbath day uh and and if you know I
think that you need to be careful that
you are not giving the impression that
it's okay for you to keep the Sabbath
but it's not okay for your family to
break the Sabbath if it's in your power.
So I think it's important that we you
know give this illustration that if is
according to help and serving the Lord
said it is good to do you know to save
man it's good to do something good in
the Sabbath but if it's to receive for
yourself any type of um you know
remuneration or or income or of any kind
I think then then you're maybe breaking
the concept of the Sabbath as it's
supposed to be a day of rest for
yourself and to break away from all the
labors that you do every
Let me add this little nuance if I may.
Um and and and try to to harmonize both
ideas which I think are are great and
correct.
Um what if if u your friend is an Uber
driver and wants to borrow your car to
do Uber work on the Sabbath? I think the
the distinction here may be somewhat
artificial in that the only things that
can rest on the Sabbath are living
things. If it's if it's not living, it
can't rest. So, um, you sort of you sort
of back into that. If I were going to
loan my wheelbarrow to a guy on the
Sabbath, and that's the the reason for
this question, I believe, I would want
to know, why are you borrowing my
wheelbarrow on the Sabbath? uh I can
give it to you Sunday, but if you're
going to if you're going to work in your
yard on the Sabbath, I don't know if I
want to be part of something
facilitating your breaking of the
Sabbath. So, I may say I'll drop it off
myself on Sunday morning, not give it to
you on on on the Sabbath. Um depending
on what you're going to do with the car,
um maybe yes, maybe no. I I think we
have a a a a moral obligation to find
out how
our implements, our tools, our the
things that we own are going to be
employed uh during the Sabbath hours
because this question presupposes that
whatever is going to be done is going to
be done during the Sabbath hours. So it
may be good to ask some questions so
that the things that you are
facilitating are not things that would
be de facto breaking of of the Sabbath.
So, so what um what would happen if
you're lending the wheelbarrow to a
Gentile
on the Sabbath? You know, you say, "Oh,
no. I can't lend you my my wheelbarrow
because I'm a Sabbathke keeper." Um you
know, if if you're lending it to someone
who knows about the Sabbath and you're
not supposed to work upon the Sabbath,
uh that's one thing. But if you're
lending it to someone who doesn't have
the foggiest idea concerning the
Sabbath, what would you do then? you
would just give them kind of a Bible
study on the Sabbath and explain the
reason why uh you're not able to lend
the wheelbarrow because you know that
they're going to be using it on Sabbath
for secular purposes.
The question assumes that the person
doesn't know anything about me. In other
words, he's my friend. If he's my
friend, he's going to know that I keep
Sabbath. So, we're not we're not
starting from ground zero. We're
starting from a a position of knowledge.
Um, and if and if I've been a Sabbathke
keeper and my friends don't know, then
the fault's on me. Uh, because they
ought to know because I am a Sabbathke
keeper, right? So, you can kind of back
yourself into the corner, but sometimes
it's it's good to ask some questions um
so that you know what's happening and
what's going on. So, it would be it
would be a good witnessing opportunity
is what you're saying. I dare say if
they don't know, now you know. You you
tell them explain the Sabbath. Good
witnessing opportunity. Yes, indeed. I
think that you know we see sort of
somewhat what is the duty that we have
those that know the truth in regards to
how we shine the light to the world in
the time of Nehemiah. Remember how they
were breaking the Sabbath because
Gentiles were coming to sell things on
on to the Jews and the Jews were buying
and so Nemiah had to shut the doors and
prevent them from coming. you know, he
he couldn't change the life of the of
the Gentiles, but he needed to make sure
that the Jews who knew the truth kept
the Sabbath holy. So, it's important
that we tried to be intentional in our
experience. And if if we know, again, if
we're going to help somebody and they
need the card to go do, you know, for
their own needs to supply for their
needs, I think it's very important to
give them. I mean, there's no problem on
that. But if it's if it's to be a day of
work for some individual and it's is
something that I think it's better for
us to explain to him like look why don't
you come and trust the Lord let's you
know learn about God and you will
realize that the Sabbath is a blessing
to you and so perhaps that's what I
think would be best to do with the
Sabbath you know I mean to be a way to
witness about how the Lord can help you
and make you a better individual and a
better family. So yeah, that's what I
think in that in regards to this this
this question.
It's good. Yeah, faster. No, I'm good.
Okay, said. Let's go on to question uh
this next one. This is June who is
writing from Kingston, Jamaica. Um she
wants an an end
timeline. U at what point are the
plagues poured out? when does probation
close? And she references Revelation 22
uh 11-12. And C, if the plagues are
poured out after probation closes, can
one assume that the
1444,000 will be living during the time
of the plagues? Oh, and she's got a D uh
from Revelation 22 again. I would think
that there would be there will be no end
for an no need rather for an intercessor
as each person will be and she uses the
word frozen in that spiritual condition
that he or she is in at the close
probation until Christ makes his
appearance.
So they all they all come from the same
uh sort of basket of uh of theology and
uh she wants basically the time but the
questions sort of build on each other to
almost to the point of answering
answering each other. Um at what point
are the plagues pro closed poured out?
Excuse my uh reading here. Um and I
think her answer would be at at the
close of probation. Um, but you want to
walk your way through this? I think
Revelation 15 has the answer to the
question of when the plagues are poured
out. Uh, Revelation 15 uh begins by
describing seven angels who are about to
pour out the seven last plagues. Yes.
Then a little later on in the chapter,
it talks about uh about the temple
closing. And the word temple is naos,
which in the book of Revelation appears
16 times. And it always refers to the
most holy place. So it says nobody is
able to enter into the most holy place
until the plagues are finished. Right?
So So in other words, probation closes.
And after probation closes, the plague
angels pour out the seven last plagues.
Correct? And at the conclusion of the
seven last plagues, in fact, the seventh
plague is actually the second coming of
Christ. Correct. with the armies of
heaven to rescue those who were subject
to a death decree before this. Uh so u
and by the way Revelation 22 uh verses
10- 12 has three specific moments of
time. Mhm. Uh Revelation chap 22 and uh
verse uh 10 through 12. Notice that
there's three three points of time here.
I can read it for you, pastor. Okay. It
says, "And he said to me, do not seal
the words of the prophecy of this book,
for the time is at hand." Okay, stop
right there. Um, the book is not sealed.
It's referring to Revelation, right?
That means that a message can come forth
from the book. Correct? And so it says,
"Don't seal the words of the prophecy of
this book of Revelation." And then it
says, "The time is at hand." What time
is at hand? Well, the next verse tells
us. It's the close of probation,
correct? He says, "He who is unjust, let
him be unjust still. He who is filthy,
let him be filthy still. He who is
righteous, let him be righteous still.
He who is holy, let him be holy still."
This is the time that she refers to as
as quote frozen. Yes, that's what she's
there. In other words, their case has
been decided forever. Right. Precisely.
But I wouldn't use the word frozen. I
will not because during the time of
trouble, the faith of God's people will
grow.
It's kind of Did the three young men who
were thrown into the furnace, was their
faith stronger when they came out of the
furnace? Yes. Was Daniel's faith
stronger when he came out of the lion's
den? Amen. Will will the faith of God's
people be much stronger after God
delivers them from the time of trouble?
Of course, they're frozen. Their case is
frozen in the sense that probation is
closed. Jesus is no longer receiving
sins in the sanctuary. He's no longer
interceding. And therefore, their case
is decided forever. But that doesn't
mean that their faith and trust in the
Lord is not going to grow as the trials
become bigger and bigger. Um and then of
course uh the last verse, verse 12, you
want to read that? And it says, "And
behold, I am coming quickly, and my
reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his work." So that's the
second coming. Yeah. So you have
revelation, a message coming from
Revelation, but the time is at hand when
all cases are decided and after all
cases are decided, Jesus comes. So you
have the three moments of time in in
these verses in Revelation chapter 22.
Therefore, so then we say that after
provision ends, the plagues are clearly
going to be put out until the very last
one, which is the coming of Christ. And
so, um, yeah, I think that answers the
questions to to our friend June. And
there's one there's one thing which the
person definitely has right, and that is
that the 144,000 which are the living
saints, yes, are going to be alive
during this period. Absolutely. because
because it's be become common in the in
Adventist scholarly circles to say that
the 144,000 are the redeemed from all
ages. Yeah. But that's not possible
because Revelation 15 refers to this
group as being victorious over the
beast. Yes. Over his image and over his
mark. And that can only be after that.
That can only be at the end time. At the
end time. Right. Uh so they are the ones
who will go through the time of trouble
alive and will be alive when Jesus
comes. Amen. And the and the key is is
his mark because the mark of the beast
only be only becomes in for in in
enforced when the the death decree is
passed. Absolutely. So it they have to
be alive. Well done, pastor. Well done.
Good said. Um let's see if we can get in
this last one before our time slips
away. This is from Ira from the
Philippines.
Um, is it wrong to question God?
Well, if you have true faith, you
wouldn't be questioning what God does
and what God allows. But we're dealing
with human beings who many times their
faith is weak. Um, we have many examples
in the Bible of people who question God.
Yes. Yeah. For example, Jonah. Mhm. you
know, he was kind of angry at God, got
angry at and you know, God didn't strike
him down. God listened and God tried to
reason with him. You have Job from
chapter 3 to chapter 40, Job is
complaining to God, why is this
happening to me? I consecrated my life
to you. And and God is simply listening
and then he answers at the end. Uh in
Revelation chapter 6:9-11, you have a
group of martyrs that are crying out, uh
why lo you not avenge our blood over
those who are shedding our blood. And
God answers. He says, you know, just
hold still until the the rest of the
martyrs is complete and then I will
avenge you against the harlot and I will
give you your reward. And John the
Baptist is another example. you know,
when he was in prison, John the Baptist
actually sent a message to Jesus saying,
you know, are you the Messiah or are we
to expect another, right? Uh, you know,
he wasn't struck down. Um, but uh Jesus
uh sent the two disciples of John back
uh to to explain to John that Jesus was
the Messiah. And then he he got his
answer and he died in peace. So there's
many examples in the Bible of people who
question God. And it was a sincere
questioning of God. Yes. It wasn't uh it
wasn't somebody who was lost and who was
blaspheing God. There you go. And I
think that's the key. It's it's the
heart that that that the question comes
from. Um Pilate asked Christ, "Are you a
king?" Christ took the time to answer
him. Yeah. You say, "I am, but I'm not a
king. My my kingdom is not of this
world." Later on, he came back with the
smart alec answer. Well, what is truth?
That came from a different mindset and
Christ didn't bother answering. He's
changing the subject. Right. Right. He
he Well, what's truth? You know, you are
the truth. Look, what's you know, who
knows the truth? You know, so it's the
mindset that that that that brings the
question for him. The first time Pilate
really wanted to know. The second time
he's being a smart alec for one of a
better terms, and Christ didn't bother
responding. So, it really is hard. In
Job
uh you know one time God is very patient
but in Job 38 God says okay where were
you you know when I when I created the
because the question is coming from a
different place so it's what's in your
heart and of course God knows what's in
your heart when you ask the question and
you know speaking of Job we can actually
see that once
Job heard from the Lord his answer uh I
like how he replies in verse 40 I'm
chapter 40 verse three four and Five. It
says there, "Then Job answered the Lord
and said, behold, I am vile. What shall
I answer you? I lay my hand over my
mouth. Once I have spoken, but I will
not answer. Yes, twice, but I will
proceed no further." So, it's sort of
like realizing when you when you trust
the Lord and and he does answer you. I
think through his word, he can answer to
you. you will realize it was silly of me
to question the Lord, you know, and
instead of and I know sometimes in your
like Elijah, you know, and and like you
other examples you mentioned, sometimes
people question the Lord uh about their
experience, but ultimately you'll
realize the Lord had all under control
and everything that's happened to me,
it's it's in his care. My life means and
matters to the Lord. So there I
shouldn't be questioning whether the
Lord is hearing me, whether the Lord is
with me, whether the Lord is uh guiding
my life. He is with me. He's guiding my
life. And like Job said, well, I have
nothing to say. You know, you you I
realize I I spoke foolishly. And uh it's
kind of the experience that I think
people that love the Lord will realize
sooner or later that, you know, God has
so many more things. And the best thing
to ask God is what Lord you want me to
do instead of why Lord. Were you were
you reading from chapter 40? I was
reading chapter 40 verses 3-5. Okay.
Let's read chapter 42. Correct.
Uh uh verses uh 1 through verse 6
because here Job amplifies much more
than what we find in chapter 40. It says
there, "Then Job answered the Lord and
said,"I know that you can do everything
and that no purpose of yours can be
withheld from you. You asked, "Who is
this who hides counsel without
knowledge? Therefore, I have uttered
what I did not understand, things too
wonderful for me which I did not know.
Listen, please, and let me speak." You
said, "I will question you, and you
shall answer me. I have heard of you by
the hearing of the ear, but now my eyes
see you. Therefore, I have myself
and repent in dust and ashes. Powerful.
Exactly. Powerful. Says, now I get it.
He says, I get it right. Why? Why did I
bother to question you? Exactly. And
that's the ultimate experience that we
are to have, you know, with the Lord to
tr truly realize that he has an answer.
And even though we don't understand what
happens to us now, the answer will be
given to us in due time. and we will
realize that it was futile was childish
of us to even question the Lord. Having
so said, truth does not run away from
inquiry. It it accepts it. It it it
almost demands it. Uh if it's truth, it
will stand up under inquiry. I mean in
Isaiah 1:18, come let us reason
together. That that that bespeaks a
certain question and answer, a certain
servant valley. And if it's truth, God
does not ask us to follow him blindly.
Ellen White says the steps of Christ, he
gives us ample evidences for our faith.
So it's not a leap in the dark. You
question, I have answers. As long as
your question is sincere, I don't think
God is afraid of questions. What he
doesn't want you to do is give up on
him. But question him, he can take the
questions. He's not he's not a baby. If
it is a sin to qu to ask God questions,
then Jesus would have been a sinner.
Yeah. Because on the cross he said, "My
God, my God, why have you forsaken me?"
Right? Because he felt forsaken. Uh and
so, uh it's not a sin to question God.
Amen. Uh as long as your heart is right
with the Lord. You're sincere. You don't
necessarily understand everything.
There's nothing wrong with uh
questioning God. Mhm. When Ellen White
was was beginning her ministry and the
Lord was calling her, she had many
questions. Uh, one of them was, "Lord,
if I'm going to go out and talk to these
men and tell them I have voices and and
and and hear voices and get message,
what's going to keep me from getting a
big head? What's going to keep me from
going off the rails?" And the Lord made
a covenant with her. He said, "Through
suffering, I will keep you in line." So
no, you can question him as long as your
question is sincere, the product of
faith, and you plan on doing what the
answer is once you hear it, then you'll
you'll be fine. God actually told her,
uh, you know, if you get all full of
yourself, I'll strike you down.
Precisely. That was the covenant he made
with
her. Again, we pray and hope that this
this sitting together has been a
blessing to you. It certainly has been a
blessing to us. Keep on studying, keep
on praying. We'll see you again next
week. Bye-bye.
[Music]